[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara
guten abend schön dass sie dabei sind
wie auch rudi cerne für den sport hallo
schönen guten abend und das sind die
themen von heute
russische erfolge im osten die ukraine
verliert eine weitere stadt im don was
und drängt auf mehr schwere waffen
ausstieg aus der kohleverstromung große
industriestaaten wollen mehr klimaschutz
deutschland und usa beanspruchen eine
führungsrolle und
probleme mit ec- und kreditkarten wegen
eines softwarefehlers bleibt
bargeldloses bezahlen bundesweit
eingeschränkt
helft uns diesen sinnlosen krieg zu
beenden so die verzweifelten hilferufe
aus der ukraine
im moment wird über ein ende nicht mal
verhandelt russland gibt daran der
ukraine die schuld der ukrainische
präsident sagt russland sei
offensichtlich noch nicht bereit für
ernsthafte friedensgespräche im osten
des landes rücken die russischen truppen
immer weiter vor franziska von
tiesenhausen
rückzug aus wie man diese handy
aufnahmen sollen zeigen die ukrainische
soldaten unter feuer die umkämpfte stadt
im norden der region donetsk verlassen
die prorussischen separatisten melden
sie hätten die man eingenommen eine
unabhängige bestätigung gibt es noch
nicht die stadt ist ein strategisch
wichtiger verkehrsknotenpunkt ihre
eroberungen könnte einen russischen
vormarsch auf slogans und grammatik
ermöglichen die unter ukrainischer
kontrolle stehen weiter östlich liegt
hier werden jetzt die stadt gehört zu
den letzten gebieten in der region noch
hanske die von der ukrainischen armee
kontrolliert werden sie steht seit tagen
unter dauerbeschuss von den einst 130
tausend einwohnern sind die meisten
geflohen die die geblieben sind suchen
in dunklen feuchten kellern schutz
ich versuche nicht über die
bombardierungen die explosion
nachzudenken ich will nein ich muss dass
ihr einfach überleben
von drei seiten greifen die russischen
streitkräfte an um die regionen donetsk
und lugansk unter ihre kontrolle zu
bringen die ukrainische armee steht
enorm unter druck der außenminister
drängt deshalb erneut auf
waffenlieferung
der einzige punkt in dem ausland uns
überlegen ist ist die menge an
verfügbaren schweren waffen ohne
artillerie ohne mehrfach raketenwerfer
werden wir nicht in der lage sein sie
zurückzudrängen
den ort pro partner haben pro russische
truppen bereits eingenommen doch nach
wochenlangen kämpfen ist nicht mehr viel
davon übrig
seit kriegsbeginn stellen sich die
menschen in odessa die bange frage wann
trifft es uns die millionenstadt liegt
am schwarzen meer und hat einen für die
ukraine extrem wichtigen hafen noch
stehen die russischen truppen zwar über
100 kilometer entfernt klar ist aber
wohl auf längere sicht gehört odessa zu
ihren zielen unser reporter johannes
hano ist dort und berichtet von angst
aber auch dem willen zum widerstand
mit ferngläsern suchen sie den horizont
ab bei gutem wetter könnte man sie sehen
die russischen kriegsschiffe die weit
draußen vor der küste von odessa kreuzen
wir sind in einer der unzähligen
befestigungsanlagen der stadt hier
bereiten sie sich auf eine russische
landungsoperation vor
wir haben seit beginn des krieges damit
gerechnet dass sie kommen wir verstärken
und befestigen unsere anlagen jeden tag
auch wenn es derzeit ruhig sei nur
deshalb die hohe sei trügerisch meinen
die soldaten die russischen truppen
hätten odessa als ziel nicht aufgegeben
an manchen tagen schicken sie 20 30
drohnen über unsere position
ein paar hätten sie hier schon vom
himmel geschossen immer wieder spenden
drohen ukrainische verteidigungsanlagen
und strategische ziele aus der
ukrainische geheimdienst warnt die
bevölkerung die kriegsschiffe und u
boote vor der küste hätten gerade neue
raketen geladen wir sollten die gefahr
nicht unterschätzen sagt uns der
sprecher des gouverneurs
es ist gefährlich in der stadt die
raketen können jederzeit einschlagen auf
wo wir jetzt stehen aber eines ist auch
ganz klar wir werden nicht aufgeben wir
werden
regelmäßig heulen die sirenen über der
stadt mehrfach seit beginn des krieges
wurden auch zivile gebäude von raketen
getroffen die millionenmetropole ist für
russland ein strategisch wichtiges ziel
der ukrainische generalstab geht fest
davon aus dass russland versuchen wird
und dass er einzunehmen um die ukraine
vom seezugang abzuschneiden sollte man
damit erfolgreich sein dann würden
russische truppen an der grenze zu
rumänien stehen an der südostflanke von
nato und eu noch aber deutet nichts
darauf hin dass eine russische
landungsoperation unmittelbar bevorsteht
aber nur besser bereitet man sich vor
über den russischen vormarsch und die
ukrainische truppen spricht zdf heute
live um 19 uhr 30 mit unseren reportern
vor ort und dem ex nato general egon
ramms in der zdf- heute- app und auf
unseren social media kanälen als zweites
mitglied der bundesregierung ist
entwicklungsministerin svenja schulze
nach kiew gereist sie besuchte den
schwer zerstörten vor ort borodjanka den
menschen sprach sie sofort hilfe aus
deutschland
185 millionen euro seien bereits
bewilligt das geld ist unter anderem für
den wiederaufbau von wohnungen und
stromleitungen vorgesehen
anderes hochbrisantes thema die
erderwärmung
aufhalten lässt sie sich nicht mehr aber
bremsen beim treffen der zuständigen
minister in berlin haben sich die
industrienationen der g7 auf ein ziel
geeinigt den abschied von der
klimaschädlichen kohle kraft allerdings
ohne einen konkreten termin patricia
wiedemeier es sind die industrienationen
die für einen großteil des weltweiten
co2 ausstoßes verantwortlich sind also
müssen und wollen sie auch mehr für den
klimaschutz tun das ist eine der
botschaften heute aus berlin vom treffen
der g7 umwelt energie und klima minister
es ist daher wichtig dass wir ganz
grundlegend nachhaltiger wirtschaften
schonender mit unseren ressourcen
umgehen die g7 stehen zu dieser
verantwortung
diese herausforderung an
dekarbonisierung also weg von fossilen
brennstoffen wie kohle gas und öl ist
das ziel wie das erreicht werden soll
dazu wenig konkretes auch die ziele
selber eher unverbindlich vereinbart
wurde dass die stromversorgung bis 20 35
überwiegend dekarbonisierung wird der
verkehrssektor bis 20.30 in hohem maße
dekarbonisierung sein soll 100
milliarden pro jahr für
entwicklungsländer zur verfügung
gestellt werden um überhaupt noch in der
lage zu sein in 20 jahren über
problemlösungen zu diskutieren müssen
wir im jahr 23 24 28 30 jetzt energisch
handeln nur deutschland und
großbritannien haben bisher konkrete
pläne für einen kohleausstieg für
umweltverbände war das g7-treffen ein
fortschritt aber sie werden immer noch
nicht ihrer internationalen
verantwortung gerecht dafür ist es
notwendig dass die g7 sich verbindlich
zu einem kohleausstieg bis zum jahr 2030
bekennen und auch ab dem jahr 2030 keine
pkw mit verbrennungsmotor mehr neu
zulassen und exportieren die usa und
deutschland wollen vorreiter werden in
sachen erneuerbare energien
unterzeichneten am morgen entsprechende
absichtserklärungen aber große co2
produzenten wie china und indien die
waren heute nicht dabei
nach dem massaker an einer grundschule
in texas spaltet amerika wieder die
frage müssen die waffengesetze
verschärft werden die chance dass sich
was ändert ist allerdings gering in den
usa gibt es mehr schusswaffen in
privatbesitz als bürger laut statistik
1,2 pro kopf und die waffenlobby ist
mächtig heute trifft sie sich zu ihrer
jahrestagung in texas claudia bates
berichtet
vorbereitungen für die jahrestagung der
waffenlobby nra
ex-präsident trump wird hier sprechen
alle werden ihr bedauern ausdrücken und
beklagen dass die demokraten die
schießerei politisch ausnutzen wollen
für schärfere waffengesetze hier sagen
sie dazu nein
so ein böser mit waffe ist braucht es
einen guten mit waffe der ihn stoppt
waffen töten nicht menschen töten
bei den hinterbliebenen der ermordeten
kinder kommt zur trauer nun die wut
eltern waren bereits vor der schule als
der täter noch darin war rund 40
polizisten hätten dort gestanden aber
nichts unternommen eltern flehten die
polizei an ihre kinder zu retten wurden
jedoch zurückgedrängt
die leute sagten geht rein schnappt
ihnen die drei in jeder minute hat er
getötet jeden moment boom aber niemand
wollte sich in gefahr bringen also sind
sie nicht reingegangen
diese kinder hätten nicht sterben müssen
nach zwölf minuten erreichten die ersten
polizisten den tatort flüchteten aber
vor den schüssen des täters auch die
verstärkende bundespolizei soll zunächst
daran gehindert worden seien in die
schule einzudringen erst nach insgesamt
90 minuten griff die polizei zu
rückblickend war das natürlich die
falsche entscheidung und es gibt dafür
keine entschuldigung der zuständige
polizeichef ging davon aus dass der
täter sich verbarrikadiert hatte und
keine kinder in gefahr waren
die polizei wird noch viele fragen
beantworten müssen
im streit über die unabhängigkeit der
justiz geht polen einen schritt auf die
eu zu das parlament in warschau hat
beschlossen die umstrittene
disziplinarkammer am obersten gericht
aufzulösen sie konnte richter bestrafen
oder auch entlassen die auflösung dieser
kammer ist voraussetzung für corona
helfen der eu in höhe von rund 35
milliarden euro
wie sehr kinder und jugendliche unter
der korona pandemie gelitten haben
zeigen neue zahlen der krankenkasse dak
danach stieg 2021 bei den zehn- bis
14-jährigen im vergleich zum vorjahr die
zahl stationäre behandlungen wegen
depressionen um 27 prozent bei
angststörungen um 25 prozent und bei
essstörungen um 21 prozent
nicht erst seit corona sind praxen und
kliniken voll und arzttermine knapp und
entspannung ist nicht in sicht im
gegenteil
glaubt
420.000 ernst innen und ärzte arbeiten
derzeit in deutschland mehr als 80.000
davon gehen bald in ruhestand warnt der
deutsche ärztetag von den unis kommen
pro jahr rund 10.000 nachwuchsmediziner
die aber sind oft nicht bereit die
bisher übliche arbeitsbelastung
mitzumachen sabine com berichtet
noch schnell ein anruf aus der
intensivstation und schon zur nächsten
patientin gerade junge fachkräfte wie
man ja gartner haben oft das gefühl an
ihre grenzen zu gehen und so den
patienten nicht mehr gerecht werden zu
können
die assistenzärztin hat deshalb die
notbremse gezogen und arbeitet in
teilzeit
ich arbeite sehr gern als ärztin und
möchte das auch sehr gerne langfristig
tun können und das kann ich nur wenn es
mir gut geht und mir geht es nicht gut
wenn ich 60 stunden die woche unter der
belastungen der welche ausgesetzt sind
arbeite
49 prozent der ärzte fühlen sich einer
umfrage zufolge häufig überlastet und
die belastungen könnten zu nehmen jeder
fünfte arzt geht schon bald in rente
umso wichtiger der ärzte nach wurst dass
wir aktuell fordert ist eine aufstockung
der zug platz zahlen um 6.000 schulen
plätze weil wir glauben dass wir diese
kollegen kollegen brauchen um auch in
zukunft die eltern der gesellschaft
vernünftig versorgen zu können und wir
fordern gute rahmenbedingungen für
ärztliches handeln in praxen und
kliniken der mit die kollegen kollegen
gern im beruf bleiben das wird enorm
viel geld kosten
bundesgesundheitsminister lauterbach
unter druck die probleme sind klar
erkannt es ist zu machen also das
schichtmodell das sind die also
pflegekräfte die fehlen es ist die
belastung die also zum teil überwältigen
das klar ist viel zu tun wie kann das
erfahren wir den schwerpunkt meiner
arbeit sein greift die kranke aus reform
nicht überlegt assistenzärztin gartner
möglicherweise in die pharmaindustrie zu
wechseln doch dann würde der 31-jährigen
genau das fehlen was ihr so wichtig ist
der kontakt zu ihren patienten
jetzt so ein problem das derzeit in
manchen supermärkten drogerien oder
tankstellen auftritt bargeldlos zahlen
klappt nicht weil die entsprechende
technik streikt ein
software-fehler der viele auf dem
falschen fuß erwischen dürfte denn
inzwischen laufen 61,5 prozent aller
einkäufe im einzelhandel
bargeldlos die schadhaften
bezahlterminals finden sich unter
anderem in geschäften von aldi nord
rossmann und edeka hans
berger an der ladenkasse sowie in diesem
hamburger outdoor geschäft funktionieren
schon seit dienstag vielerorts tausende
solcher karten zahlungsterminals nicht
mehr selbst größere summen können nur
bar beglichen werden ja es hat einen
umweg und dementsprechend zum
geldautomat und wir hatten die spannende
frage ob dann noch der geldautomat
ausreichend geld hat werden überall
keine kartenzahlung möglich ist das
problem haben aktuell auch viele
discounter filialen tankstellen oder
drogeriemärkte es sind kartenlesegeräte
eines älteren typs bei denen offenbar
die datenübertragung an den
zahlungsdienstleister nicht mehr möglich
ist der hersteller wollte sich bisher
auf anfrage nicht konkret äußern auf
seiner website teil damit dass man mit
höchster priorität an der behebung des
problems arbeite und in kürze ein
software update bereitstellen werde doch
bis das überall angekommen ist könnte
noch zeit vergehen meinen experten wir
gehen davon aus dass das ein bisschen
dauern wird weil es sich um einen etwas
größeren fehler handelt bei dem die
geräte ausgetauscht werden müssen vor
ort für den betroffenen einzelhandel ein
ernstes problem dass umsatzeinbußen zur
folge haben könnte wenn die leute dann
mit der ware geforderten in triesen
kommen und dann erfahren dass sie nicht
mit karte zahlen können dann überlegen
sie sich das vielleicht noch zwei mal
oder gehen dann einfach ohne etwas zu
kaufen und war dann im zweifelsfall ins
internet ab wie lange die terminals noch
gestört bleiben ist unklar kunden
betroffener geschäfte bleibt solange nur
immer ausreichend bargeld dabei zu haben
es ist spektakulär aber auch ein
bisschen gespenstisch was da gestern
abend in london premiere feierte vier
jahrzehnte nach dem letzten auftritt
steht aber gemeinsam auf der bühne
beziehungsweise täuschend echte avatare
die die mittlerweile über 70 jährigen
schwedischen superstars in jugendlicher
frische zeigen das publikum war
begeistert
aus london andreas stamm
eine premiere von pop historischer
bedeutung aber nach 40 jahren wieder
vereint für eine zeitreise in die eigene
vergangenheit sogar das schwedische
königshaus unterstützt sie
wir sind glücklich wieder zusammen zu
sein zusammen zu arbeiten die nach hause
kommen
ich bin sehr nervös gleichzeitig sehr
aufgeregt und ich habe es noch nicht
sehen können
zu sehen eine musikalische
wiederauferstehung
[Musik]
die originalstimmen ihre bewegungen
alles aber
aber alles nur licht die helden der
siebziger popmusik konserviert als
hologramm
[Musik]
fantastische animation als ob aber
wirklich auf der bühne waren eine
einzige party ich kann es nicht in worte
fassen es hat jede faser in mehr berührt
ein fast 1000 köpfiges team hat die
avatare auferstehen lassen eine
projektion der band von 1979 und 160
kameras wurden die songs mit den
originalen wochen lang gefilmt
digitalisiert und verjüngt
das comeback-album aus dem vergangenen
herbst wohl das letzte bett touren
wollen aber definitiv nie wieder dafür
kann die gesamte halle ab und anderen
ort wieder aufgebaut werden sollte die
für immer jung show in london ein
kassenschlager werden
[Musik]
wer weiß wie lange wir noch in echt
stehen
du hast deine stimmt angelique kerber
ist bei den french open in paris
ausgeschieden beim zweiten tennis grand
slam turnier des jahres unterliegt die
deutsche nummer eins alexandra sadovic
aus belarus mit 4 6 und 6 7 die
siegesserie von angelique kerber ist
nach sieben nacheinander gewonnenen
spielen gerissen trotz einiger guter
erster aufschläge und einem besseren
start im zweiten satz war sie die meiste
zeit die getriebene sie fand nicht zu
ihrem rhythmus der eindruck sie hätte
schon fast aufgegeben war für ihre
gegnerinnen geradezu eine einladung ihr
aggressives spiel durchzuziehen ihr
kampfgeist kam zu spät und zu selten
definitiv war ich jetzt nicht bei 100
prozent ich habe sehr viel kraft die
letzten tage gelassen aber trotzdem habe
ich versucht alles zu machen um so
schnell es geht zu regenerieren der
einzug ins achtelfinale ist der bislang
größte grand slam erfolg für sadovic
bei der kanu slalom em in der slowakei
hat das deutsche team im canadier
wettbewerb gold gewonnen am zweiten
wettkampftag siegte das trio mit dem
olympia-dritten sideris tasiadis ex
weltmeister franz anton und timo trummer
im mannschaftswettbewerb vor polen und
spanien
morgen abend steigt im staate france in
paris der größte showdown des
europäischen klubfußballs das finale der
champions league fc liverpool gegen real
madrid auch das duell der beiden trainer
jürgen klopp und carlo ancelotti
so mancher verbindet ein gefühl der
sehnsucht mit paris sportlich gilt das
auch für die beiden besten europäischen
fußball mannschaften jürgen klopps
liverpooler stehen bereits zum dritten
mal innerhalb von nur fünf jahren im
finale der königsklasse
gegner real madrid ist der
rekordchampion und vergessen das finale
dieser beiden teams 2018 dass die reds
unglücklich verloren
ich werde mich logischerweise viel
besser fühlen wenn wir diesmal gewinnen
und im moment mache ich mir
ausschließlich darüber gedanken wie wir
das schaffen können
nach dem gewinn der beiden nationalen
pokal könnte liverpool morgen den
dritten saison titel einfahren
also morgen 20 25 der finalabend live im
zdf und um 1920 schon das champions
league magazin du weißt was du zu tun
hast absolut ich danke für den hinweis
ich immer um höchstleistungen ja einen
weltrekord ging es auch gestern im
nordenglischen whitby dort hatten sich
am abend
1369 vampire um die abtei ruine
versammelt der anlass vor 125 jahren
erschien der roman dracula teile der
geschichte spielen in whitby autor
bremsdruck aber angeblich bei einem
besuch hier zum schreiben des grusel
klassikers inspiriert worden
durchwachsen und kühl das sind die
wetter stichworte fürs wochenende
nächste woche ändert sich das schon
wieder die details hat gleich katja
honnefer marietta slomka begrüßt sie um
10 im heute journal wird danken für ihr
interesse wünschen ihnen ein schönes
wochenende und dann tschüss
minuten
[Musik]
guten abend heute zu ein kleines
wolkenband hier von der mitte
deutschlands weiter richtung süden das
war eine kaltfront den alpenrand hat
diese kaltfront noch nicht erreicht und
über norddeutschland so gefiel schauer
hinweg zum teil auch gewitter mit
schauern und gewittern geht es in
norddeutschland auch in der nacht weiter
zum teil ist es auch klar und die kleine
kaltfront erreicht den alpenrand südlich
der donau bleibt es diese nacht unter
diesen dichten wolken vergleichsweise
mild mit 12 bis 10 grad die gibt's auch
an der nordsee sonst aber wird es kalt
mit 9 bis 4 grad und in den
mittelgebirgen droht vielleicht sogar
noch einmal bodenfrost kalt bleibt auch
morgen über tag zumeist mit 13 bis 17
grad und allenfalls am mittel- und am
oberrhein geht auf 18 bis 20 grad drauf
morgen vormittag kann es am alpenrand
noch ein bisschen regnen sonst wechseln
sonne und wolken mit einander ab und es
gibt viele schauer ab und zu auch mal
blitz und donner und die kräftigsten
schauer geht's wohl zwischen berlin und
nordfriesland bei einem starken bis
stürmischen wind aus nordwestlichen
richtungen am sonntag ändert sich an
diesem wetter wenig es wird sogar noch
ein bisschen kälter aber in der neuen
woche steigen die temperaturen von tag
zu tag wieder an guten abend